overnight the Deep fakes oh my God you
see the one of Patrick Mahomes as Kenny
Powers no you can't tell it's uncanny
yeah no so we started off they actually
do a nice uh party for us at the hotel
The Chainsmokers came through DJ Khaled
came through you can't beat that man
that's every genre of music you need
right there and then uh how crazy is
that yeah this is the um
Minecraft realm sorry about yesterday
whatever guys I'm gonna reset the realm
and we can all start from fresh cool
with you gang say less Drilla sounds
just a young team stop with these gay
ass names bruh also Joe wink your sleepy
ass up this time and download the right
[__] game God damn it shut the [__]
up you literally look like a hairy
[__] orange what regardless I knew I
downloaded the wrong game last time bro
so why the [__] did your rotting ass not
say anything about not wanting to play
Minecraft first of all Pixel Gun 3D is
goated as [__] it's foreign